joining us now is the french member of
the european parliament
also a member of the eu fisheries
committee stephanie john cortan thank
you very much indeed
for joining us first of all what what
is illegal breaking the brexit agreement
about what's happening in jersey
well what is illegal is that the treaty
hasn't been uh respected and what we
want is uh
definitely the respect of the whole
treaty only the treaty
and well you know it's uh very
frustrating it seems like a shock really
very surprising
um and it's a bit it's devastating the
the very good relationship we had so far
between you know the fishermen
french fishermen and and fishermen
jersey and and the whole relationship
basically between the
normandy territory and uh and the jewish
territory
so um um well you know it's just uh
it's just a nonsense that the fishermen
had to cope with the unilateral measures
regarding their licenses which has been
shortened or
limited to a certain spaces which
is not at all provided
the cooperation agreement following
brexit
but does that justify blocking the port
of centelia that surely
is illegal in international law
yeah it is illegal and i mean as you may
know it just uh
we will always favor let's say the
dialogue of a retaliation with which is
of course a last resort measure
this is not about threats this is about
reminding that
retaliatory measures exist first in the
in the trade agreement
uh and sending the navy is a classic
boyce johnson tactic
as well he needs a distraction from his
problem in the uk probably
what we want is just to treat the french
fishermen correctly
as the uk and jersey authorities treat
their fishermen
and we've got a long tradition of very
good relationship over the
the past uh decades between the um
jersey fishermen and french fishermen
and we want that uh to
to carry on and to continue but i mean
the
french fishermen are very upset by the
current uncertainty
they don't yet know when a lot of people
i mean a lot of people are very upset
but but are you saying you actually
support this blockade this morning
well i i'm i'm just i mean i would
prefer to have a proper dialogue and to
stop
you know blockade but the thing is we
have to make sure that uh
we we can um you know solve the thing
um and uh so i think really uh i support
the uh
our fishermen as i support the work of
the uh
jersey fishermen as well when they want
to uh
you know operate in them in the french
waters as well
you also so really i i wish that jersey
and the uk government will act in good
faith and respect the agreement
in full it's not only about fishing
licenses in jersey it's about
applying and respecting the treaty
between both parties the treaty
following the brexit you know
what about the threat to cut off
jersey's electricity
uh by by the french supplier what do you
make of that
well um it's again it's a last resort
threat
and of course what i want is just
to make sure that we come back to very
good
uh and classical good relationship and
classical relations and we always favor
dialogue as i said over retaliation but
it's necessary to see that
we will act firmly using all the tools
we have in the agreement
and much more than that so i mean
everybody needs to understand that our
fishermen need to be supported
and need to work and it's very very
disappointing to see that
there are some there have been some very
surprisingly
uh unitarian conditions attached to the
lessons
um and and all the our fishermen were
very surprised to discover that
the treaty is not respected at all what
we want
yeah yeah but listen hang on hang on
i've got to put it to you
that the aggression and the escalation
of this situation does seem to be coming
from the french and the eu
side that yes britain voted
democratically to leave the european
union
yes an agreement was reached to do that
yes we'd all like to see that settled
through
sensible negotiation but what we're
getting
as we got over the vaccine row is
very heavy-handed threats coming
from the european union that's not a way
to resolve
a change relationship between the two uh
blocks is it
i don't think it's a threat it's just a
reminder as i said that there is what to
cut off electricity to blockade ports
i don't think that's a threat to stop
vaccine exports i mean all these things
are threats
i'm not talking about vaccines i'm
talking about the fact that electricity
is still on
it's still on and it's not uh it's it's
not
um done already the idea is
of course uh if there is no
positive reply and outcome from the uk
and jersey we will have to
um you know explore any ways to uh
make sure that our fishermen are heard i
really want
because i i really appreciate our
people from jersey and i know that there
is full of solidarity because the
um french and jersey fishermen
so i really would like that you know
there's no it like it's an
instrumentalization
of our fishermen by politicians so
that's the first thing
and i want i mean i really want i don't
want any war i don't want
any threat uh it's not an uh it's not an
heavy threat
as i said it's a reminder that the
treaty has to be
respected in full and only the treatment
yeah but my point is you're not
respecting the diplomatic process
when you support things like this
blockade when you threaten to cut off
electricity that
that's extra diplomatic i mean that is
straightforward
crude confrontational politics as we're
now seeing and that's not going to make
it easier is it
to resolve this matter sensibly that's
why we need to discuss
we need to discuss and i understand that
i mean i i want to favor a discussion
first
an agreement first and dialogue first
i'm urging
the parties which are um the commission
and uh the french minister
and the french government which is uh
closely uh
watching following that and uh and the
uk
to discuss together and to make sure
that jersey
on its part decides to levy all the
unconditional and
on this on this conditional story and on
this
legal measures so that we come back to
normal
right but so what you want is the uk to
respect the rules
but your side doesn't respect the rules
is that right well we are respecting the
rules i don't know what we are just
showing that we
we want everybody to respect the rules
we haven't what have we done
so far which is unrespectful which is
illegal
our fisherman okay that's that doesn't
mean we want
um let's say business as usual we want
having the same good cultural
relationship with our friends
and we want a good negotiation i mean
it's not a negotiation at all it's just
going back to normal
and i'm sure uh what i like as well is
that
any fisherman can be treated the same
and that we are not obliging them um
with a surprising with a lawful
with illegal conditions which are not
provided in the treaty
while earth are we negotiating
why on earth the european parliament has
ratified the treaty last week if we
don't
uh apply it again it's not a teething
issue as some can say because you know
i mean it's not only about fishing
licenses in jersey it's a matter of
trust you know partnership to respect
their commitment
today's fisheries what will it be
tomorrow
hope it can be resolved stephanie uh jan
kotta thank you very much indeed for
joining us